bonjour à tous j'ai voulu vous présenter
la plateforme qui va nous permettre de
travailler sur nos idées notre projet
ses idées ce projet que nous avons
exprimé depuis longtemps depuis des
années dans le combat politique de tous
les jours au parlement pour certains au
parlement européen pour d'autres et puis
dans la vie politique et dans le sur le
forum comme on dit médiatique mais il
faut mettre de l'ordre dans ses idées et
nous avons décidé le conseil national a
décidé que nous allions ouvrir une
plateforme collaborative qui s'appelle
agora d'elle c'est un joli mot qui
évoque la démocratie la plus antique et
naturel la démocratie sur l'agora agorad
m et agoras dame point fr va vous
permettre d'intervenir vous même
directement sur chacun des grands
chapitres que nous allons discuter de la
vie du pays
des orientations et des changements
qu'il faut y apporter de l'élection
présidentielle et des élections
législatives qui suivront et donc sur
chacun des sujets nous allons mettre en
ligne un texte qui donne notre analyse
des questions et qui vous invite à
prendre la parole pour vous exprimer
et que ainsi le les idées que nous
défendrons elle puisse être le reflet le
plus fidèle possible de ce que notre
communauté de militants de sympathisants
d'amis porte dans le débat politique
français
agora dème point fr c'est votre affaire